[Musique]
marjo vous êtes la reine du rock
québécois oui vous allez chanter sur les
plaines d'abraham pour le spectacle la
fête nationale comment expliquez-vous
qu'encore aujourd'hui vous avez le rock
dans la plaie j'aime la musique et la
musique dans moi je mentirais si
j'arrête et je le jure puis deux en plus
ma mère est native de québec faites moi
quand je rentre dans québec chine
j'ai l'impression d'être la suite demain
ce que je suis d'ailleurs mais pour moi
qui ai vécu c'est dans mon cas et c'est
la fierté d'être québécois
[Musique]
ouais
4 m'apaise dimanche au succès des mises
en surchauffe oui
j'ai retrouvé dans nos archives une
entrevue de 1981 et vous dit la phrase
suivante je penses tu que je vais
chanter du rock n roll jusqu'à l'âge de
50 ans on est encore ici alors que ce
qui s'est passé vous avez changé le
monde avance 69 incroyable mais vrai dix
postulants chanter du rock and roll call
âgé 55
[Musique]
non je vais d'ailleurs quand je rentrais
d'un combo je ne visualiser peau comme
bon ben moi je vois faire de la musique
jusqu'à santa non statique
[Musique]
visait pas je fais est évidemment entré
ça si ça marche on a dit un homme en
prison jusqu à dix mois du moins qui ce
qu'était exactement corps bouge c'est
complètement fou 1978 à 1984 c'était la
vie sexe drogue et rock'n roll
la question qui tue comment vous avez
survécu à
charge que j'avais jean miller
qui est un garçon très très tranquille
lui me remettait toujours à ma place
mais je pense que quand on quand on
rentre dans le vrai c'était d'ouvrir à
quesnoy où j'ai vraiment j'ai vraiment
vécu à fond comment j'ai survécu j'ai
mis fin à corbeaux
jezzine jamais assez de cette vie
[Musique]
malgré le succès de promo sans le sucre
que vous avez été hospitalisé après le
succès de votre premier album solo parce
que c'était comme juste trop gros t'es
trop vraiment je ne m'y attendais pas
mais non voyons dont 250 et l'album
n'est pas prêtre la place dans l'église
c'est simple on fait de la musique pour
lg pour être avec les autres donner de
la joie du bonheur de l'entrée puis le
bain ça s'en vont montrer trop c'est
beaucoup trop alors oui j'ai fait
anxiété sévère je sauvage du jour
l'été 1987 mauvais temps marqué parce
que chaussons manche à jouer partout
j'ai fait mes vaches on n'avait pas le
marais cela c'était la chanson de l'été
1987 et 35 ans l'album je l'avais
intitulé c'est l'équivalent d'après moi
c'était la chanson que le texte était
vraiment vous et puis non ces chats
sauvages que mon chat sauvage sur un
texte de bilal que je sais que c'est sur
la liberté mais c'est pour
jeunes filles comment on si je commence
à écrire je commençais à dire que
j'étais un petit peu mieux que corbeau
geagea bordel je peux plus les déboutait
remet voilà mais c'est ses entrées de la
place comme je n'attendais pas
non vraiment
0 c deux chansons elle est pour
vous faites tout un cadeau pour
septembre prochain vous allez être coach
à la voix n'avait pas sorti d'album avec
des chansons originales depuis plus de
15 ans qu'est ce qui se passe parce que
vous avez un compositeur parolier
j'aimerais bien sûr je crois que ça va
arriver après la voix je pense que s'il
ya quelque chose qui va se passer après
l'avoir même le pourquoi du 15 ans c'est
que depuis 2014 j'ai décidé que je
prenais ma vie de musicienne et
d'auteurs en main donc je fais tout et
la logistique est rarement trouvé les
bons musiciens des fois j'en ai c'est
jonas pas ça je m'occupe de tout tout
tout tout donc ça s'apprend être un
malade je ne fais que ça les gens qui
veulent avoir marjo soit en entrevue en
radio le blabla passe par marjo sur mon
courriel et moi je réponds à tout le
monde
[Musique]
alors de 28 ans vous avez dit en
entrevue il est temps que je m'arrache 5
au bout ouais est ce que vous êtes
assagi ah oui maintenant je cultive mon
énergie parce que j'en ai besoin mais
oui un va mon énergie je l'affiché
partout je m'insurge tu avais je me
rendais pas compte que je la dépense et
au fur et à mesure et maintenant tu vois
quand même cette semaine j'ai avec
quatre événements donc je me suis dit ok
le premier c'est bull 2e c'est vous
autres il ya ici de la répétition a été
uni nous demandait de la faire à fond
donc fallait chanter pour ouvrir ce sens
qu journée a alors un stage dormi
marjo à satan vous dormirez monsieur je
crois pas si bien oui pour revenir en
forme aujourd'hui
les quatre jours que j'ai fait c'est
beaucoup marjo m'avait fait un beau
cadeau qui se baladent immense plaisir
je t'aime
[Musique]